- So, jetzt haben wir alles zusammen. Jetzt
können wir den Teppich sauber machen.
Jetzt bauen wir das erst mal alles auf.
Rein damit! So.
Das ist das Erste, der Treibteller.
Das ist der Treibteller.
Dann müssen wir die Maschine
ein bisschen kippen.
Da kann man schon sehen: einmal rein,
so, und einmal drehen.
Jetzt ist es fest. Okay?
- Hab ich verstanden.
- Alles klar.
Dann kommt das Pad drauf,
und dann kippen wir das wieder zurück.
Und der erste Vorgang ist fertig.
Jetzt müssen wir das alles anschließen.
Das saugt das Wasser ein
und die Chemie später.
- Und hier?
- Das ist fürs klare Wasser,
noch zum Nachspülen.
Dann musst du ziehen, bis es klickt.
Dann müssen wir das hier oben auch
anschließen.
Hier einmal.
Also, das schmutzige Wasser später zum
Neutralisieren kommt dann hier rein.
So ...
Und dann müssen wir das aufmachen.
Da kommt das klare Wasser rein.
So!
Dann kommt jetzt hier Wasser rein in
die Einscheibenmaschine.
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier Chemie:
Teppichreiniger.
- Kommt auch hier rein?
- Hier kommt jetzt Chemie rein,
das ist Teppichreiniger
Für den Fleck hier.
Nicht zu viel.
Wir starten.
Siehst du, wie das Wasser jetzt
da unten rauskommt?
Immer kreisende Bewegungen machen,
dass du auch jede Pore mit Chemie füllst.
Dann wenn man hier fertig ist,
geht man ein bisschen runter.
Wo man hier den Fleck sieht –
mehr Chemie drauf und
länger draufbleiben auf dem Fleck.
So, jetzt sieht man hier keine Flecken mehr,
dann kann man die Einscheibenmaschine
auf Seite tun.
Jetzt sind wir mit dem ersten
Arbeitsvorgang fertig.
Stellen wir die ab.
Jetzt kommt das nächste Gerät.
Also, hiermit saugen wir jetzt das …
… die Chemikalien weg.
Also, es kommt vorher das klare Wasser,
und dann saugt man beides ab sozusagen.
Hier muss man gleich draufdrücken.
So.
Und dann wird das dann alles
sauber gemacht.
Ich mach das jetzt an.
Für den Wassersauger und
für das klare Wasser zum Nachspülen.
Langsam.
So, willst du mal versuchen?
- Ja!